we are each born in to this world without choosing
to our parents , to our certain location of time and space ,
to the particular conditions of our body
as we open our eyes we peer out at a world
moving around and onto us
we exist here and in the oncoming fleeting moments of our infancy
with no say in any of it
soon we will age past infanthood and  into
cognise in awereness of self
and the material world around us
and soon to paraphrase the existentalist philosopher
jean paul sartre. We will begin to face the problem of choosing what we do
with what has been done to us , to decide what we make of everything
what it all might mean
and what we do with it
Jean paul sartre is one of the most widely recognized
thinkers of existential philosophy
a movement of thinking that took form during the nineteenth century
fashined by indivudals like soren kierkegaard , friedrich nietzsche,
and fyodor dostoyevski
and then further popularized
by indivudals including albert camus martin heiddegger and of course sartre
and ofcourse sartre
in sartre's lecture existentalism is a humanism
he famously summarized the primary existential principle
with the line " existence precedes essence"
essence here , meaning the qualities of a thing
that creates its purpose for example
sartre references how a paper knife  is designed  with the specific
purpose in mind before it is made and only once it is given a predetermined
purpose and designed accordingly
it is manufactured  into being in which case essence
preceds existence. with exception to itself
humanity does this with nearly everything it makes. As rational beings
we create out of reason even if the reason
is to make that point we can create things for no reason
we have nearly found ourselves in a paradox of creating for the reason of
having none which remains a reason
we exist with the innate desire
for  reason. What we do who we are
why we are and so on
and here lies the beginning of our existential problem
according the sartre and many others there is no predetermined
meaning or reason to human life
there is no authority figure designing us or our lifes
and there is no essence to our existence prior to our existence
but rather life exist for itself and beyond itself
it is tragically meaningless
whenever our sense of reason and logic confront this potential realization
to the nature of life including the most essential part of our life
ourself , appears to not  agree with the same order of reason
we can often find ourselves in a sort of existential crises
however sartre and the existentialists dont see this as despairing
but rather justification for living
if we are not made with the specific purpose prior to being
we create our purpose through our being
in other words only through the choices we make and the actions we take in life
can create who we are and what life means
"man" sartre  said " is nothing else but what he purposes , he exist only in so far
as he realises himself  , he is  therefore
nothing else  but the sum of his actions nothing else but
what his life is." the by product of this is
life's inherit meaninglessness isnt inherit freedoom
freedoom to choose who we are how we live and what matters to us
and here we experience the next round of our  existential problem
the anxiety or anguish of choice
with essentialy in  infinite potential number of choices
in combination of choices for how to live and think and be
the anxiety of  choosing properly can be rather heavy
ironically though the choice we make here, in reaction to
the anxiety of choice , is perhaps the most important choice of all
the easier knee jerk response to the anxiety of choice
is simply just not choosing
to mindlessly assumulate popular common tamplates and ideas of life
Following standard beliefs and purpose laid for thrust
and deflecting nearly all the responsibility of choice onto others
and the circumtances of our lifes
however sartre referred to this as bad faith
a form of lying to ourselves and deniying  our basic freedoom
a short term attempt  to damping the anxiety of being
that in turn cause the potential loss of our true self and  true sense of the world
even choosing to not choose is still a choice
there is no escaping the requirement of choice
choice can only be minimized to choosing or not choosing
and this is perhaps the fundamental existential choice
to choose or not the choose. For in this choice
one either harnesses  the anguish of the human freedom or relinquishes it
either builds a life of  intention or  lives
a life of complacency
we each have our little flickers of time here
no one else will ever know much if any of what it is like to be who we are
and for the most part no one will ever really care
our life is ultimately our life
and so long as we are not harming  others  in the process
we must create a life of our own meaning
determining our own objects of importance committing to their pursuance
and reaping the significance in wonder of life along the way
truthfully we sell them  sufficient enough information to properly make
any choice. including how much we might agree with sartre or any one else
through out our life we are faced with serious decisions about what we believe
who we are and what we do and mostly none of it is
self evident and if we look we always  find a reason to regret
any decision we make
move or stay , agree or disagree
take the job or quit, marry or divorce,live one path or another
in all cases whatever the choice maybe
we will only ever know the outcome  of the one that we take
and none we take will ever ultimately resolve the uncertainty of life
however perhaps it is less about getting a potential course of life right
and more about attempting to do so with an effort of self honesty
and virtue to live a life that can be looked back out
with the knowledge that some of our decisions were perhaps wrong in their effects
but right in their intention of not selling ourselves short
it is ofcourse incredibly hard and complicated to grapple with life
to consider the abstract concepts
of existence and meaning and being however the
overwhelm and challenge found on this and the world full of uncertainty
absurdity and responsibility is perhaps the unavoidable
price of the great gift that we are all given at birth
but it is just that a gift
and the face up to the abyss to feel the anguish of choice and potentiality
to bear the weight of self . all are about
humbling beautiful  reminders of
of life running through our veins and perhaps our only
job is to realise this and make the gift worth its price
agree with sartre or not , ultimately his ideas
are reminder to do just that , to risk the easy and common place
for the unique and great
to work towards our full potentials in the face of all obstecles
including ourselves. To take responsibility for our life and what we make of it
ultimately no matter what we do or say or believe
there will be always great many who disagree or judge
or become upset by our decisions
but it is essential importance that we
to ensure that among those people
ourselves is not one of them